Ah, theme parks.
Don’t ya just love ‘em?
They’re great places to eat $12 hot dogs,
see countless kids on leashes, and….
pass kidney stones?
Hey peeps, Crystal here for DNews.
You may have heard of kidney stones and how
painful they are.
Chances are, a few of you have had to suffer
through them already because ten percent of
people will have a kidney stone at least once
in their life.
One of these unfortunate souls claimed he
passed his stones while riding a roller coaster!.
Researchers followed up on his claim and found
that the bumps and jolts of a roller coaster
can help kidney stones make their way through
the body, with a 64% chance you’ll pass
the stone!
Crazy, right?
But what exactly are kidney stones and how
do they get in your body?
Kidney stones, also known as nephrolithiasis,
are small, hard mineral deposits formed in
the kidneys that pass through the urinary
tract and leave the body through the urethra.
For those of you that don’t know, *whispers*
that’s where your pee comes out.
They typically occur when some of the minerals
in your pee become highly concentrated.
See, your urine has over 3,000 different compounds
in it, including salts and a wide variety
of minerals.
When the amount of fluid gets out of balance
with the minerals, or when your urine lacks
the right substances to break them up, they
may clump together, forming a kidney stone.
One of the most common types is formed when
a compound called calcium-oxalate becomes
highly concentrated.
These are aptly named calcium stones.
Kidney stones, in general, vary in shape,
texture, color and size.
They can be as small as a grain of sand, as
big as a golf ball, smooth, jagged, or even
sharp.
I don’t know about you guys but I definitely
don’t want a sharp, golf ball sized object
coming out of my urethra!
Most kidney stones are passed out of the body
in a few days, but they can sometimes take
weeks.
Ouch!
The buildups can cause excruciating pain in
your side, back and lower abdomen, frequent
and painful urination, nausea, and bloody
urine.
Some people have even said that passing a
kidney stone is more painful than childbirth!
The amount of pain you’ll feel is pretty
dependent on the type of stone.
Smaller ones can easily be passed with the
help of lots of water and some pain medication.
But more serious stones may not come out that
way.
Sometimes they’re too big to exit the urethra
and sometimes they’re wreaking too much
havoc on the kidneys and urinary tract to
be left alone.
Stones that can’t be passed naturally will
need to be broken up by shock waves, surgery,
or a scope that’s inserted up the urethra.
So obviously the best thing is not to get
these bad boys at all.
One of the main causes of the buildups is
not drinking enough water, which allows the
salts and minerals to build up and stick together.
Your diet can also make a difference.
Certain foods, like spinach, nuts and chocolate,
have a high concentration of calcium oxalate.
And medical conditions like gout, urinary
tract infections, and certain metabolic disorders
can increase your likelihood of getting the
stones.
Even your genetics could play a part because
kidney stones can run in families.
So if your gramps has had ‘em, be sure to
keep an extra eye out for any symptoms.
But if you get stuck with them anyway, maybe
just take a quick trip to a theme park to
speed up the process.
Have you had kidney stones before?
Was it as painful as it sounds?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know in the
comments down below.
Thanks for watching!